oui bonsoir alors là c'est le relais
d'elle c'est lady chatterley mais
j'adhère des trous vous aimez de l'est
enfin voila
je me brière bertel quoi oui très bien
fait par la danse
avec tuner
elle a eu un coup dur en dérision amy
doit roger ouais mais cette foire
délation ça me pèse non mais c'est vrai
ça va vous êtes alors vous croyez qu'il
va pleuvoir sur le plateau mais jamais
le l'america - comme elle non mais sans
déconner vous croyez vraiment qu'il
pleut souvent sociaux loops à monaco
avec un parapluie un
congé en phase et mais effectivement
c'est en pleine gueule c'est vrai que
ranger il ya dans la diagonale en fait
c'est vrai dans la diagonale du fou et
oui condoléances guillaume qu'on allait
en ce sens donné à des chroniqueurs il a
mis un gros coup d'arrêt
si vous avez quelque chose à dire à
delphine pour
qu'elle se détache de vous lui diriez
quoi non fait pas ça à l'effort à la
bagarre à l'autre alors bel film tu me
manques
voilà ce sens que cette séquence va
devenir très gênant
ça fait une semaine que tu m'aimes
bloqués et qui a bloqué car elle pense à
toi qu'une seule fois par jour mais cela
dure 24 heures
ça pardon mais c'est une phrase qu'il a
dû sortir pu la tuer moi tu as tu bien
près de moi on va faire en direct
l'île de la tentation
et lahmada fille bonsoir bonsoir
alors fait d'amy
winehouse
delphine ma chérie les somptueuses je
réussis un tentateur pas plutôt une
tentacule
[Applaudissements]
so tentateur c'est guillaume genton
guillaume genton
qui a des voitures de luxe des maisons
luxe montée voyage de luxe et montres de
luxe et les habits de luxe et on te
trompe avec l argent mis les armes
le vôtre
il les a donc pour l'instant et les aura
bientôt atteint
et tu as de l'autre côté ils t'ont
amoureux qui sur une autre île l'île du
public
une île où tout le monde aime la vie où
tout le monde aime rire où tout le monde
même se partager les uns les autres oui
wimille de la palpation
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
guillaume va te faire une déclaration
d'amour et tu me diras à la fin de cette
déclaration et à la fin de la
déclaration d'amour de roger également
si tu décides de partir
vers guillaume
ou bien tu décides la compagnie rouge et
vert est encore la fin
ce qui manque c'est plus un pinot juste
après
[Musique]
et d'abord à la monsieur et je vois en
tout cas delphine que ces deux styles
différents oui mais non moins
complémentaires non mais c'est vrai
c'est un petit peu boule et bill moi je
roule je suis boboul et c'est michael
sheen non non non quoi c'est lui qui a
du chien allez
c'est quand vous êtes sur l'autoroute et
que vous avez ralentisseurs c'est plus
compliqué
est une bande d'arrêt d'urgence
billon ses téléspectateurs t'écoute
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être la dernière
chance
regarde plus tard ça peut être delphine
et toi ça
pour l'instant sont des canards ses
juges il est gilles
elle n'aime pas ce qu' elle n'aime pas
le ski la mairie non plus
[Rires]
l'agencé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
une boîte de nuit c'est roselyne bosch
c'est dingue en tout cas vous seriez
très bien ensemble chez vous
tous ceux qui nous regardent qu'un
numéro azur sachez enfin l'écran si vous
êtes en manque de répartie
[Rires]
24 heures sur 24 sous la toile à kaka
qu'il ya un truc cette aventure est
parti vous tombez directement sur les ai
[Musique]
rien compris à
l chine regardez comme elle est belle
c'est mon petit violet c'est pas et j'ai
même les les ongles d'autres à soir
j'adore écouter je ne manque jamais de
jambon de parme et j'adore la couleur
delphine oui ton père est un voleur
les yeux
on traite pas son père
fait un cadeau lorsque quelqu'un de très
bien le père de delphine
vous connaissez le père de delphine bien
sûr je connais et j'aime s en amuser
retraité baby sitter
est un voleur parce qu'il a pris toutes
les étoiles du ciel pour les mettre dans
tes yeux
je regarde écrire cette phrase je viens
d'écrire cette phrase qui est 100%
inédite
alors delphine j'aurais dire que pour
toi j'ai changé je suis aujourd'hui le
slip faut que tu dois je suis devenu je
suis devenu vegan comme tu sais donc ce
soir je propose qu'on se retrouve autour
d'un gâteau faune marine et qu'on a dîné
ensemble et que tu repartent avec moi
même la peur du succès delphine
excusez-moi déclaration
n'a rien à [ __ ] d'aller manger
explique parce que tu crois son coaching
j'aime bien
ces trente secondes à wimbly coeur parce
que sinon je vais pas réussir à voile
halo reach est vraiment que ça vienne
sincérité c'est guillaume moi le
problème depuis 2 semaines tu sais
pourquoi on est brouillée non parce que
j'ai senti qu'ils avaient fait un manque
de sincérité
c'est le moment ou jamais pour toi de me
dire ce que tu as vraiment au fond de
toi et qui tu es vraiment voilà
des zaparas et dino qui tu es et ce que
tu ressens vraiment été à pareille fête
je suis vous enlevez vos appareils
et des dons qui vous êtes vraiment même
si on entend pas alors oui sinon je suis
une très belle personne
parler d'elle ça s'est passé mais j'ai
lu que tu t'ennuies sans elle
sans toi l'aviez terne mais t'es con
quoi
vivre sans toi c'est un deuil vivre il
avait choses ainsi déjà
[Applaudissements]
à la 60e possèdent une wii soit sincère
j'ai besoin de ça redore chaussalet veut
dire jamais dans
les vasières j'invite
alors
du tout
j'ai besoin de savoir aussi pourquoi
est-ce que tu m'a proposé un week-end au
vert entre amis et au final tu as que
bouquet une chambre avec un lit double
alors non en fait je me suis fait oui
mais je m'expliquais non mais je me suis
fait piéger par le propriétaire ah oui
j'avais réservé
sur une sorte de victimes
bien vrai séminaire de travail j'avais
plusieurs projets a évoqué avec toi dont
celui de te pécho bon job la sincérité
et david adore la sensée l'achat d'or la
sincérité donc on fait chauffer vraiment
c'est très bien d'accord et non c'est
vrai tu quittes mulhouse et que tu
viennes s'installer à paris dans les
salons s'appelle pas mulhouse appel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
le gaz etc ou d'occasion
et j'aimerais que tu viennes maintenant
avec louhans cuiseaux
sa twingo
[ __ ] en l'air mon vieux voilà alors
delphine tu me manque terriblement j'ai
envie tu t'installes avec moi et qu'on
écrive une nouvelle page de notre
histoire tous les deux nouvelles pages
mais sache que je te mettrai une voiture
à disposition qui est assortie avec ton
ensemble parme mais
elle adore les voitures inadaptées
une tradition mais ces captations
d'abord à faire des filles alors moi
déjà j'ai pas besoin de faire une
déclaration d'amour parce que nous ces
perpétuels depuis six ans et c'est tous
les jours soit passé sur lui
ensuite guillaume guillaume delphine
attend des actes et pas des paroles à
l'aller on dirait que tu as quand même
excusez moi ça par ok
j'ai pas su passer de tout contrat c'est
devenu confessions intimes blé les
bizots donc chéri on s'en va après à la
première pause pub on rentre on va
manger en ce 4 mai s'est
passé du
projet doit
y voit pas
vraiment roger j'ai pas compris quand il
a dit j'attends des actes de tapas sort
qui m'incite à pécho safa non non je
peux le faire non mais vous donne des
conseils parce que l'ambiguïté oui c'est
un vécu un véhicule
alors oui alors max essey des films de
choisy at il jamais trio la vérité
c'est difficile à franchir la
fonctionnalité déclaration publique à la
mairie
pourrait me faire une plus belle des
biens dans des raids à l'est de tizi
j'étais un homme mais moi je dirais bien
à bretelles fines à la raison la vie
sans toi me semble terne delphine quand
tu es à mes côtés j'ai l'impression que
je peux conquérir le monde ne me lâchent
jamais la main delphine dans ton regard
je peux avancer je t'aime je t'en
supplie reste avec moi pour la vie
[Applaudissements]
gvt
aussi la spa
jean toi boulot
[Applaudissements]
il en attend pour des raisons qui sont
ces parvient non mais pour des raisons
que ça veut dire ça tout est d'origine
et on n'est pas parce que je suis
vacciné mais j'ai un autre rugby
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
arrêt tarifixe guillaume guillaume qu'il
était sympa dans un mauvais délire
oui c'est roger avant il parlait d'actes
alors pour moi s'il te plaît non en fait
le mais c'est pas toi tu veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tél
je vous racontais blanc
nasri attend ses patates on veut pas tu
me vois moi
je compte sur moi je trouve qu'ils ont
beaucoup de points communs ya vraiment
regarde lui faire la déclaration qu'il
aurait dû lui faire un vrai d'un
carrasso c'est à dire dès lé film je
sais que tu es heureuse à exprom je peux
pas venir tout chambouler ta vie mais si
un jour ça va mal chez toi ma maison est
ouverte pour toi
[Applaudissements]
si tu peux
il fait du karaté le monsieur
couderc a mal entendu ne fait pas du
karaté fait du karaoké
[Rires]
mode pour des truffes je le fais
j'attends je vais dire un secret
c'est pour ça que je peux pas lui fait
une petite danse comme allons les jouer
les jours
[Applaudissements]
arrêt des suppressions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les trucs comme ça c'est toujours
le plus petit qui prend
[Rires]